the talks got off to a difficult start
in march some factions walked out
demanding greater representation they
insisted members of the transitional
military council or tmc not run for
office there is a commitment from the
government side but if you look at the
rebuilt side the issues are that is
where it is begin to get very
complicated because you have no
demand going it seems like the
mama debbie shouldn't stand for
re-election or return of cis assets you
have to also reconcile the competing uh
rivalries within even between the the
opposition and rebel movement because
while they might be forming a unified
position you have about 40 groups
present in in the process in doha the
draft agreement is meant to pave the way
for a national dialogue later this month
and the new constitution
chad has been locked in internal
conflict for three decades
idris debbie came to power in 1991 in a
military coup and served as president
until his death last year
fighting among armed groups has forced
hundreds of thousands of people from
their homes
when his father died 37 year old
muhammad debbie took over as president
and heads the 15-member transition
military council
he is credited with bringing rival
militia to the negotiation table but the
absence of some of the main opposition
figures from the signing on monday
rekindles doubts about the
sustainability of the deal
chad is one of the poorest countries in
the sahel and with decades of drought
and armed conflict it is in urgent need
of stability there is an air of
happiness and optimism here among the
delegates with me here is fadol hussain
he's going to he is from the
national council for reform he's one of
the 42 organizations or groups that have
signed this agreement and he says he's
happy why are you happy what's different
about this agreement because this peace
agreement there is a lot of
international community involved
to observe or to
to
to continue to see where the peace in
chat so that's why it's a lot of
delegations here today
first of all the
united nations african unions and
countries
around the chad they all they came here
today to see the peace
agreement that's why today we are very
happy very pessimistic and then the
the muhammad idris debbie he will come
he he came here already to see all the
the
political uh movement here to to say uh
to appreciate them to sign the peace
agreement it seems that not all
charities are ready for peace because
some of them have not attended this
ceremony today and they have not signed
one of them is one of the most active
groups in child militarily
yeah the peace agreement is still open
and then it's still open for everybody
to come join the peace agreement in the
future so we urge and then today i urge
everybody if he didn't sign and then
because this is a historic agreement for
the chadian so anybody who didn't sign
he will continue to sign the the
the peace agreement is open so for
aren't you concerned that one of the
main factions an armed faction
very active in the country has not
attended and has not signed it
so there is a hesitation for the fact so
because they stay here for five months
to to negotiate with the chadian
government but i have the optimistic
they are welcome in the future to sign
the peace agreement or to join this
peace agreement
so that's why you know like uh or the
chadian government still they have
the demand for everybody in outside the
country will come and then to join the
peace
thank you so much
hussein from the national council for
reform so basically the 42 groups that
have signed this agreement today they
say they are very optimistic they said
this is the biggest
the biggest gathering and the biggest
deal of its kind that chad has seen chad
has signed dozens of similar deals in
the past but they said this is the
greatest and they said it's time in chad
everybody in chat is tired of war is
tired of conflict and they believe that
with the help of qatar and other
countries and the un and the
uh and the african union and because the
champions are ready for peace now and
tired of war they think this agreement
will last